[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Наддніпрянщина
Біла Церква]
Це — Томмі Генріксен,
який грав на нашій гітарі.
[Олександр Дорошенко
Засновник «Юніверсум Гітарс»]
Ось, до речі, сама гітара,
на якій він грав у європейському турі.
Це музиканти Еліса Купера.
Це український метр рок-музики —
Серго Чентурія.
Джон Патітуччі — найвпливовіший
басист у світі.
Ось така наша гітарка у нього.
Ці інструменти за ціною добрих світових брендів,
адже практично все — ручна робота.
Ці інструменти для поціновувачів
екзотики, колекціонерів,
а також для музикантів, які роблять шоу.
Наші інструменти — живі.
Музиканти одноголосно кажуть, що ці інструменти не заважають, а допомагають грати.
Десь кілька сотень, скажімо...
Нема завдання зробити багато гітар.
Завдання — зробити добрі інструменти.
У дорослого чоловіка була
прихована дитяча мрія.
У юнацькі роки не награвся,
бо 70-х ми грали, то було модно.
Біла Церква — моє рідне місто.
Тому і дає такі творчі сили.
Я служив в армії. Офіцер.
Займався спочатку наукою,
а потім бізнесом.
Пізніше вирішив повернутися до гри.
Зробили уже рок-групу
таких же «стариків» як сам,
щоб грати якісь старі пісні.
Я почав купувати інструменти, про які мріяв.
І одну із тих гітар зламав.
Шлях привів до майстерні,
до хлопців, які виготовляли інструменти.
Так і почалось.
Було зацікавлення, було проектування.
Усі були об'єднані
духом експериментаторським.
Оці гітари в той період
і були спроектовані.
На них ми і робили так званий «тест»:
ми давали музикантам, вони грали, а потім висловлювали свої побажання.
Проект стартував у лютому 2016 року.
До кінця квітня були вже перші інструменти.
А в середині вересня ми вже були
на першій для нас міжнародній виставці.
Це була перша гітара,
яку ми спроектували.
Це цільнокорпусний інструмент.
Вона може бути як електрогітара.
Відхиливши ручки такого цікавого
клапану, майже саксофонного,
ми вмикаємо акустичний режим.
Тут є конденсаторний мікрофон.
До нас цього у світі ніхто не робив.
Дерево, звісно, наше вітчизняне —
із Закарпаття.
Дерево дуже хороше.
Має унікальні акустичні можливості.
Ми використовуємо клен,
вільху, ясен, тополю.
Багато чого використовуємо.
Дуже високо вони цінуються у всьому світі.
Всім дуже подобається, особливо як вони звучать, бо кожна має своє особисте звучання.
Є нішеві знання про «золоті пропорції».
Я використовував раніше
ці знання на інших виробах,
а зараз вони реалізовані також і в інструментах.
Вони дають свій ефект,
і завдяки цьому про нас знає
дуже багато людей за такий короткий час.
У мене є компаньйон —
майстер з величезним досвідом.
Я займаюся публічною діяльністю, організаторською і таким іншим,
плюс — проектую інструменти,
а він це все втілює.
Це не бізнес-проект,
це — творчість.
[Вадим Гавриленко
Майстер, співзасновник «Юніверсум Гітарс»]
Ось така-от штука.
І за цю «штуку» великий відсоток населення
нашої країни готовий віддати душу.
Я маю на увазі гітару.
Навіть не торгуйтесь.
Коли з'являється якась нова компанія,
то до її продукції ставляться із обережністю.
Є така ментальна річ в Україні:
що робимо самі — не цінне,
а те, що роблять американці — ото класно.
Не так багато українських музикантів
із нашими інструментами.
Зазвичай, це люди з досвідом.
Вони розуміють, яка різниця, на чому грати.
У нас роботи зараз небагато, на жаль.
З підготовленими кадрами
в Україні дуже важко,
а з гітарними майстрами —
мегаважко.
Щоб підготувати спеціаліста,
який би міг зробити інструмент,
треба навчати не менше півроку.
Донедавна завдання масового
виготовлення у нас не було,
а зараз будемо думати:
готувати учнів, готувати спеціалістів.
Для України ми скоро будемо
презентувати інструменти.
Вони скоро з'являться, сподіваюся,
у ключових магазинах України,
і будуть за доступною ціною
для наших вітчизняних музикантів.
Знаходитись у постійній зневірі —
дуже погано, на мою думку,
бо це — самознищення.
Дуже тішить, що почалась певна динаміка:
люди починають знову грати, займатися мистецтвом, виступати,
створювати нові колективи,
брати участь у фестивалях.
Це суспільні процеси, може
люди вже втомилися жити «на мінорі»,
може вже пора якийсь «мажор»
в країні починати.
А «мажор» має починатися із культури,
бо якщо у суспільстві нема культури —
нема суспільства.
Тому тішить, що з'явився цей «мажорний» тренд
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Субтитрувальниця
Софія Анжелюк]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]